good morning
and welcome everyone to this webinar
this session is going to introduce you
to the next generation sequencing omix
logic training program
this program is going to be available in
the context
of omics logic launch in africa
bioinformatics in africa is an
international initiative
that connects multiple educational
organizations
that will be working together to bring
cutting-edge bioinformatics resources
to the community of students and
researchers interested in learning and
developing data science skill sets
relevant to the current biomedical
research
clinical r d and the biotechnology
industry so today we'll discuss the
following topics first of all we'll talk
a little bit about the omixlogic
resources and different
training platforms that will introduce
you to bioinformatics
we'll also talk about breast cancer
samples an example where we can go from
raw reads from the next generation
sequencer
and develop a table of gene and isoform
expression
and that example will give you a
snapshot of what this training will be
all about so as you understand the
way this program is organized and
conducted we will then introduce
the full curriculum and some details of
live
sessions that are going that are going
to be included in this upcoming program
now one of the major advantages of
omixlogic programs is that we will
introduce
domain experts with rich experience and
background in
current biomedical data-driven research
so the participants of the program will
have the opportunity
to not only learn about bioinformatics
and try to analyze data themselves
but also get answers about their
research ideas
and get mentor support to complete the
courses
assignments and effectively use the
resources that we are going to be
introducing
towards the end of the program we will
also discuss
how to register for this program and
access
these various resources
so before we go into the individual
components of these topics
let me introduce everyone to our team
and talk a little bit about how this
program is going to be working
so uh the main organizer for this
program
is dr mohit mazumner who has a phd in
computational biology
and he's the director of business
development and a mentor for the
programs helping to find
the right match between the mentors and
the participants of the program
and make sure that all of the resources
are being accessible
and easily used by all of the
participants
so our company briefly is based in the
u.s
but we do have an international presence
working both in universities and
with industry partners in europe the
middle east
and now in africa our goal
as a company is to provide cutting edge
bioinformatics research and training and
we work with several
university partners to evaluate
and refine the educational materials
that we provide and make sure that they
are effective
and practical for the participants from
different levels
including high school students
undergraduate students
graduate and even faculty our mission as
a company
is to simplify bioinformatics and make
it accessible
advancing research through the
cutting-edge and user-friendly
next-generation sequencing data analysis
platform called the t-balance platform
we're working with over 5000 students
and researchers throughout our platforms
to provide
research support and big data analytics
tools designed for biomedical data
discovery
this all has been made possible due to
the efforts
of a rich interdisciplinary team
including the co-founders of the company
myself ilya brodsky and dr
alfred tauber and dr erlina brodsky who
is the director of the tower of
bioinformatics research center
and an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics so what we will discuss
today is also a result of
hard work by some of the people
mentioned here on the left uh julia
panov who is an expert bioinformatician
and helped prepare many of the materials
we will use addition who is a computer
scientist and leads the development of
the teamviewer platform
joshua mccandle who helps maintain the
educational web portal that we will
leverage
dr harpreet kaur who is our onyx logic
trainer and expert bioinformatician
and beeps abyss for us our community
manager that i'm sure many of you have
met already
through the emails so let's talk a
little bit
about omixlogic programs
that we offer and how live sessions are
going to
uh help you leverage the materials that
will be included in this program
including some online materials for
asynchronous learning
like the hands-on courses projects
assignments
quizzes and the certificates number two
we'll talk a little bit about the
analytical platform the t-bind for
platform
which is a user-friendly implementation
of complex bioinformatics
pipelines and allows us to process
analyze and visualize multi-omics data
and also we'll talk a little bit about
the data science component of
bioinformatics
bioinformatics where you will learn
about r
and python coding intended for
biologists with minimal background
to rapidly advance their skills in data
science
to be able to understand data types
extract meaningful information by
analyzing that data
and visualizing in preparation for
publication
and showcasing the results
so all mixed logic programs are a result
of close collaboration between pine
biotech which is
a big data analytics company based in
the us and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content
evaluation curriculum review and project
design
as a result the omixlogic programs have
been thoroughly tested
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students and faculty
interested in bioinformatics data
science and biomedical research
so you see some of our partners here
we've done a lot
of programs with different universities
including
the louisiana biomedical research
network at georgetown university
amity university in india and we have a
lot of partners that are continuing to
leverage our resources
to provide bioinformatics experience
and project-based learning to their
students as well as research partners
that are leveraging some of these
resources
to conduct cutting-edge research
of our online training leverages
cloud-based technology to provide
high-performance computing access so we
solve the problem of
infrastructure as well as detailed
training resources
that guide you to leverage some of these
materials
and tools effectively it also makes the
learning
interactive practical and hands-on
so the two portals that we'll mention
today
are edu dot t bio dot info
and server dot t bio dot info
these portals are interlinked and you
can already start by creating a free
profile
on this link and the link is pasted in
the chat it's edu.t
bio.info so if you can go ahead and
go there and you will see a way to log
in
let me show you how
just go to the home page
so this uh portal includes resources
that you can go through starting from
free resources
and anyone can already get started with
introduction to bioinformatics
a course that provides you with an
overview of what bioinformatics
is and how bioinformatics is applied in
basic research
biomedical projects biotechnology
and agriculture so i recommend anyone
who has
minimal background with bioinformatics
to start with this course
now when you first get to this portal
you will see
right here a way to log in
this is the link where you can also
create a new profile
and you can do that starting with your
free access to most of the courses
that we're going to be discussing today
so right here you can either log
in or you can register right here
or even connect with one of your social
media profiles
once you log in you will have access
to free and paid courses and we have
basic subscriptions that require
minimal pricing so they're priced at ten
dollars per month
and you will have access to all of the
materials that you will see here
you also get a personal profile and i'll
talk a little bit more about that
in just a second
so that's the first portal edu that
t-bio
dot info it is your personal space where
you learn
bioinformatics and then start
specializing in different
subtopics including metagenomics
transcriptomics genomics and others
as you go through the courses and you
start applying
what you are learning to data sets you
will leverage
a user-friendly t-bio info platform that
allows you to use
a point-and-click interface to study
different data sets and extract
meaningful patterns
that could be interpreted from a
biological perspective
so first of all the basic membership on
the edu
dot ts bioinfo portal provides you
with 12 asynchronous courses
that include the analysis of next
generation sequencing
for genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and epigenomics so you will
find those courses available
and you can either purchase an
individual course or buy a subscription
to have access to all of them
inside each course you will find a
variety of topics that include both the
biological side
and the bioinformatics side so you'll be
able to learn
the theoretical parts and then you'll
also be able to apply
what you are learning to a practical
project
now inside there is a navigation
tool that allows you to get the most out
of this
including covering different types of
keywords that you'll be able to
understand if you're not familiar with
them
and also be able to study offline by
downloading the pdf version of the
lessons as well
now in this program our goal is to not
only tell you
about next generation sequencing and how
data analysis
could be used to understand the data but
also
to be able to process and apply all of
these
to a project of your own so in this
program
we will provide both theoretical and
practical training
for those who are interested in next
generation sequencing
that is becoming widely accessible and
helps us study
a variety of different biomedical and
other types of biological topics
in each program you will learn about the
type of data
how to process it and prepared for
analysis
and utilize data science skills to mine
and visualize
large data sets and present your
research to peers and experts for
feedback
so a big part of what we do is make sure
that this could be used
by non-technicians and non-engineers as
you know bioinformatics is a
rapidly emerging and changing
area so you do have to have
a lot of technical skills typically to
process
and analyze such data in the absence of
such experience
learning bioinformatics and applying
bioinformatics tools to study actual
data sets
can become very complicated so we've
designed a platform that covers many
areas of next generation sequencing
mass spectroscopy structural biology as
well as data science machine learning
and data visualization
that is intended not for only
bioinformaticians but also for
biologists
and clinicians so we are hoping that if
you are coming from a
life science background or in medical
school
or potentially even working as a
clinician you're probably already
recognizing the fact that next
generation sequencing and genomic data
has transformed our understanding of
many diseases
and many types of conditions so using
these tools
you'll be able to actually process and
analyze data
without any coding
how does it work so you will find a
user-friendly interface
that provides different types of outputs
that could be easily visualized and
explored to understand
what is going on in the data set being
complex data sets
you'll have to understand how these data
sets have been prepared
and what do they describe but ultimately
without any coding you'll be able to
explore a variety of different types of
data sets
and understand what they mean
so remember that during this whole
presentation
we do have a chat box and so if you have
any questions
or you would like to have more
information about any of the topics that
i'm describing
please paste your questions post your
questions in the chat box
to make sure that i can address them
during these pauses
that we'll do throughout the
presentation to take your questions and
be able to respond
so if you have any questions about what
we've covered so far
please let me know in the chat
and as you post your questions i'm going
to hand off this presentation
to dr harpreet kaur who is a trainer
with omixlogic
and we'll explain how we will cover the
material that i have described
in the upcoming program
thank you so just let me share new
slides
about me my name is harpreet kaur and i
have done my phd
in bioinformatics and i am omics logic
trainer at find biotech
today i will explain all the
upcoming program and i will show you how
we can
use or and analyze real ngs data
using tbi and 4 platform
as we are talking about real ngs data
let's look at a research publication
from where we are
we have taken this data in
in the year 2016 there was a research
article that is published in the ongo
target
where bradford at all have explored the
whole
transcriptomic profile of patient
derived genograph models or
pdx models as a tool to identify both
tumor and stromal specific biomarkers
they investigated rna-seq as a
hypothesis free tool
to generate independent tumor and
stromal
biomarkers and explore tumor stoma
interactions by exploiting the human
and mice compartment specificity of the
pdx model
across the pan cancer cohort of 79 pdx
models
they determine that the mouse stoma can
be separated
into disconnect clusters each
corresponding to a specific stromal cell
type
based on omix profiles of the sample
in their study they have explored
different cancer types
including lung and the balance breast
cancer subtypes
complete publication is available at the
foreign following url
in our program we will try to perform
various ngs analysis
using the dataset from the basin drive
genograph
that is pdx project so let's understand
what is pdx or the patient
uh genographs pdx models are generated
when a fresh tumor
obtained directly from the patient and
is implanted
into the mice through subcutaneously
or orthotopically into immune deficient
mice
others maintain the principle
histological clinical and molecular
characteristics of
original patient tumors while remaining
biologically stable
in the mice since pdx models are more
closely resemble and recalculate tumor
growth in humans
than standard in vitro cell line or cell
line
genographed approaches they remain
a key experimental platform for
preclinical drug
development
in our program we will try to analyze
two breast cancer
subtypes that is er positive and triple
negative
er positive best cancer subtitles are
identified by the presence of the
estrogen receptor on the cell membrane
while
triple negative breast cancer is
identified
by the three common uh the absence of
all the three common receptors on its
membrane
this is just one of the differences
between them that is
how it all changes but it makes one is
more treatable
while the other is more aggressive form
of the breast cancer
subtype in subsequent courses we will
using the this t by infer platform that
is already described
by ilia and the steve improv platform
to process big data cells this platform
is built for multi-omics integration
uh multi-omics integration and analysis
of structures data with advanced methods
like machine learning
mathematical modeling etc after you set
up your account at t
by info platform so make sure you try
out this analytical platform
there is a different file format in
which
ngis data is stored let's understand one
by one
what is each file format means fastq
file first fastq file provides us with
the reads from the sequences
it is text based file format that stores
reads nucleotide sequences and quality
score
quality score related to each nucleotide
then the fasta file uh is also a text
formatted uh
file it represent dnn protein sequences
typically this is the reference
reference
reference file for any genome or a
protein
and then we come to the gta file that is
genome transfer file format
which contain genome annotations
for example gtf stores the start and the
end of each genomic elements it could be
exon
isoform or a gene
this analytical platform will provide
you hands-on experience
hands-on experience for anyone to apply
learn skill to interest to interesting
data sets with color coded logical
with a logical annotation and
explanation of the methods
then detail input and output formats
reproducible workflow
so let me demonstrate how we can analyze
our raw rnas expression data and finally
generate and gene expression table
by using a pipeline on our uh
t by for platform so let's uh let me
demonstrate that
so in our tape and if uh if we move to
the t
binder platform there are the different
analytic
uh pipelines and i am here using a demo
pipeline that is that is where we have
used a pdx
project
once you start this pipeline you must
have some files
here as we have already this is a demo
pipeline so we
have already uploaded the data sets
and we you have to these data sets
provide
provided in the form of the svl files
so and we have uploaded this data set
and with the reference genome as well as
the data set that you want to
understand here we are using the pdx
links for the pdx data set
on like clicking i have uploaded this
data set
then the next step is primo matic that
removes
adapters this is pre-processing step and
once you uploaded your data then you
will perform
this trimmimetic step promoting remove
adapters so just click on this
primatic you need not to know every
coding or
you need not to do any coding program
you just have to understand your data
and upload those data and then
you can follow these steps
once you remove the adapter the next
step is
you can remove the pcr duplicates
using pcr clean step
so it is just taking a bit time
so pcr clean removes that any duplicates
of these reads
then the next step is is the for the
mapping
so you can you can perform mapping by
different
uh algorithms so here we are using but
ip2
that is that will ultimately to generate
your transcript so we to map these
reads on our genome so we will using
battery t2
so about every every single step but it
does
the explain complete explanation is
given in each step whenever you going to
perform any step there is complete
explanation on our
platform once you have
mapped the gene uh your reads with the
genome
then the the next step is to generate
the gene expression table
so gene expression table uh you can
generate uh
it will generate your read cons as well
if you choose the normalization
normalized that is
pkm then you can generate your
normalized data
in form of a table so i am
only generating the cons then you can
also perform differential gene
expression and
analysis but i am not running here
differential expression gene analysis so
i am just
i have generated a gene expression table
here and i am going to stop my pipeline
here
so once to end the pipeline you
once this pipeline is completed
you will find a various output files in
a download pipeline
folder so you can check this folder but
our file that
that you have obtained so you have
obtained
rsme expressions
pdx project pre-processing so once
i am already up downloaded this file
so i can check what kind of table i have
obtained from the
raw reads
so after running this pipeline we are
able to obtain
a simple table where samples are present
in the columns
while the genes are present in the row
this is how
this is how t bind for plate platform
will help you to generate or to perform
complex
analysis using a simple manner
you you do need not to have the
knowledge of all coding and everything
so this is how tv info platform will
help you so
uh this is the final table so if you
want to perform
any kind of analysis so you have you
have already
you able to prepare this table so now
let's
let me look at the questions if you have
okay so i see there's a question um the
question is asking how
does one know what is the next step in
the pipeline
and um could i briefly address this
question
um as you saw dr harpreet was showing
a pipeline that every step of the way
a next series of options is highlighted
eliminating the most commonly
[Music]
most common problems or um you know
wrong selection that a typical
new person in bioinformatics would make
so really
the platform guides the creation of the
pipeline
based on data input and the previous
selection that you have made
but also what we will discuss in the
program and what you will find
in the online training is that all of
these different steps are explained
building your logic and the color coding
helps you establish that logic so you
remember which color
is associated with what type of logical
step
for example pre-processing the mapping
then quantification is colored in blue
red and green so it helps you remember
and then next time when you try to apply
it to your new data set
you actually remember that you have to
take into consideration all of these
different steps
thank you yeah so let me go further
there's another question uh the other
question is what kind of data do i
upload for analysis
this depending
well let me briefly talk about different
data types
could i share my screen yes sure
okay so um there are different types of
comics data
available and one of the things that we
would do
when we are doing this program is we
will actually explore
different types of publicly available
data sets on repo
repositories like the national
center for biotechnology information
ncbi
and we'll explore here how to find data
sets
related to cancer so for example if i go
to breast cancer
you will find here thousands and
thousands of
samples that you can analyze starting
with
you can see here over 5000 bio projects
just related to breast cancer so we'll
talk a little bit about how to find
the right kind of data and the benefit
of the platform is that you actually
don't have to
download these types of data sets to
your own computer
you can directly import them into a
pipeline
so here you can see breast cancer let's
talk as an example
tuberculosis for example
you can find here uh transcriptional
response to microbacterium tuberculosis
and mouse
peritoneal macrophages right so you can
really find here
information on a whole lot of different
topics uh you can see starscope 2 in
patients with severe acute respiratory
illness in egypt
or starscope 2 from brazilian amazon so
we'll discuss
how to find these types of datasets and
how to then analyze them with the
appropriate
pipeline on the platform
did that answer your question lewis
okay excellent okay
should i pass it back on to vipsa to
explain how to register
and find all the relevant materials on
the program
um dr harpreet can take over then at the
end i will be going over
the registration process all right
great thank you
thank you
we believe that bioinformatic literacy
is key across
all stages of the data uh data
generation processing utilization and
critical decision making
it is essentially fought to
essential skills for lab technicians
researchers and
clinicians a couple of months ago
we started engaging universities across
africa
that showed a keen interest making such
training available to their students and
faculty
and resulting in this upcoming program
this and this upcoming ngs
bioinformatics training program
is a collaborative effort between fine
biotech
usa then the department of medical
laboratory
science and faculty of the basic medical
sciences lead city university nice area
also sported by nigeria med lab congo
lagos nigeria a non-profit organization
committed to the boosting the
understanding of medical laboratory
and biomedical data analysis
we will combine online sessions
self-guided study material
and practical assignments for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective
in our well-known and respected omics
logic programs
to sort this program and guide you
learning with us
you will have opportunity to interact
with a collaborative with an
international team
of experts specialized in the area of
bioinformatics and data driven research
in this one month program we will focus
exclusively
on the opportunities in the
computational biology training
and clinical research support our
mission in africa is to help a growing
community of clinicians
biomedical researchers university
students
and industry professionals
so let's look at the schedule for the
live session these will be recorded as
well as well
mail to the participants we will start
with an overview with the translational
research
and learn about ngs data and its
applications
followed by the application of the
genomics and the transcriptomics
uh in the understanding the logics of
the analysis after learning of what
two data types uh by the online sessions
and the courses that you will access
through the tbi info platform we will
start applying statistics and machine
learning
in our example data sets once we have a
proper
deeper understanding about application
of some of these techniques
then we will look into the public
repositories and that how we'll find our
data and what data is available
and where it is available and how you
can upload these data sets
on our uh t bind for platform to run any
kind of analysis
so after learning about the data the
registered students will have
access to start exp exploring the
innovative research and educational
platform
live sessions and a team of expert phds
in biomedical research
student mentor let's look at the details
of each session and this session that is
going to learn
let's see what let's learn more about it
this session will be dedicated to the
translation research
where we will learn about the overview
two
resources on the t bind for platform
and the projects the data that data sets
and the t
bind for uh analytical platform
introduction to the precision oncology
infectious disease
expectations schedule review for the
training program
and important deadlines then you have
any good q and a
sessions you if you to address your
question
the program this program is designated
to highlight the role of big omics data
that is shaping modern biomedical
innovation
where molecule data is used for
precision diagnostics
big data integration machine learning
and transforming personalization of
treatment selection
and innovative algorithms allow for
unprecedented capabilities with drug
discovery design of
large molecules and drug repurposing
the various types of omics data
describes intracellular
and intracellular processes associated
with common disease
it can be studied it can be studied to
understand the role of
various pathos on microorganisms in our
bodies and in our environment
and it also understands to pose various
infectious disease and chronic risks
risk that destabilize immune
immune system and lead to cancer
associated factors
the next session will be dedicated to
the next generation
sequencing genomics the uh where we will
going to
study dna variants and mutations
this in under this session we will be
focused on to
introduction to the next generation
sequencing reads
needs of the structures data and
associated bioinformatics
methods then what are the different
processing steps
to generate germline and somatic
mutation then to perf
how we can perform various kind of
analysis like mapping
or to detect variance and how we can
interpret
the data uh significance meaning from
this genomics data
and we how we can generate a significant
mutation that are available in
particular
disease condition or a data condition
so to learn more in a detail there are
two different programs courses are
available that is introduction to
genomics genomics one
that that's where you will find details
regarding
the genomics data and uh the deep
understanding
how these mutational data you can
explore in terms of
to study in terms of uh various to
in terms of precision medicine and how
you can generate
a significant uh
hypothesis to find out what important
and significant mutations are important
so these code this these courses where
you can learn
detail regarding genomics
we will understand we can analyze
genomic data using t1
platform and we will other we will
analyze the genomics data at mutation
label
using this t bind for platform where
you will perform pre-processing steps
you will learn about
how mutation to generate a mute
and how you can but are different
methods are available to pre-process
these data
then you how can you you align your
uh reads on a genome
to find finally to to perform a mapping
or alignment
and how you can generate variants called
different variance calling
how we can generate different uh
differential variant calling using t
bind for platform
and how we can annotate these um variant
callings or mutations
finally how we finally we can analyze
the
post process data or the outputs using t
pi info platform
the next session will be focused on next
generation sequencing transcriptomics
gene expression data so here we will
learn how we can measure
measure the function functional proteins
by the way of
mrna abundance and accurate
identification of alternating surprising
an overview of rnac read quality and
pre-processing
mapping on reference genome using
various tactics and
logics and how we can align an alignment
free quantification
and how we can quantify the genes and
the transcripts
in a particular data sets then uh
summary of the structures data
and we will learn about how we can
visualize the transcriptomics data using
pca
and other approaches and how we can
finally elucidate a biological
significance from this
complex transcriptomics data
this pipeline i have already shown its
uh demonstration to you so
if you want to further go want to go to
for detail
you try yourself once you you have
access to t
by info server platform
next session will be focused on big data
problem
setting using machine learning for the
complex gene expression data
where you will learn about big data and
complex
collections representing individual
variety requires new approaches for the
analysis
and correlation between clinical
manifest manifested
manifesting of disease and molecule
patterns that defines it
then you will learn about machine
learning approaches
that allow computational power to apply
to these challenges
and we will review the data exploration
using dimensionality reduction
like pca then we will perform learn
about clustering
methods that is unsupervised
machine learning and you will explore
how classification and discriminative
analysis of labeled data sets
can help to detect a relationship in
large-scale datasets
by supervised machine learning so we you
will go through
we will go through the unsupervised and
supervised machine learning methods
in this session
so then we have another platform that is
for the coding
and analysis so where you can run your
own scripts
and you understand how these data sets
are processed
using different uh codes so
if you are interested to understand how
these uh
you can process or you were interested
to learn
about your programming in terms of
at whether it's r or in the python so
you
you will access to this coding platform
and we will also
show you how how different um
analysis approaches are done using
coding platform
so let me uh look at some of the
questions if you have
yeah there are some questions um i think
the questions are more related to
uh the program uh training itself
in a while yeah okay yeah so when we
talk about the program
registration and how to participate
and what will be the timing and
logistics we can
mention all of that but i think that
maybe you could show a little example
with the coding i think
maybe that would be interesting
we will come to the complete uh that how
you can register to this program
just let me go ahead
so this is our coding platform omics
logic coding
we are different uh already lessons are
available so you can learn
how visualization how you can perform
differential gene expression how you can
perform
uh clustering and how you can perform
different machine learning
uh methods so the these codes are these
codes and the tutorials are available
in coding uh in in the r and the python
and
you can learn about that
in the next section
this session will be dedicated to the
bioinformatics data resources
and the databases so like ncbi
uh sra geo a ref sec and other
repositories of publicly available
research
research databases other like tcca
and cvi virus etc so where the public
data sets are available
this session is dedicated to that part
in this session we will learn how we can
extract biomedical data from the public
repositories
like geo sra etc and we will also
learn how we can upload these data set
to our t14 platform
for their analysis to drive any
biological
significance or interpretation
the last session will deals with the
final exam in the bioinformatics
research projects
here you will learn about the planning
of what your project proposal how to
present
your scientific data and how you can
generate or make a hypothesis
then there will be a question uh
question and our
questions are also available and you can
upload your presentation you give
through the audio and the video
and then you can go through the case
studies and publications and the data
sets
so this program is project oriented with
the real data
used used cases an example adapted from
high throughput
high impact publications projects are
extracted from the relevant publications
on the topics that fit
the program and student profile
publicable
public uh publicly available datasets
are curated to prepare
focused assignments that will be
illustrating
how the data is processed and analyzed
and achieve similar results to the
publication
alternating alternative approaches that
can perform a similar function
will be discussed and we provide a
review of the methods
section of the paper finally the full
data set is organized into a project
format that can be re-analyzed and
discussed by the student and the faculty
and you will also understand how you
proceed for your own project once you
able to perform
uh analysis on already public uh public
datasets
now i would i would like to
pass it on to
beefs are so that she can explain you
how we
how you can go through the registration
processes and other parts
so so please take a session
yeah thank you doctor i will be
sharing my screen now
i hope everyone can see my screen
right now let me know if you cannot see
my screen
well we can see your screen but gibson
you have a little bit of a noise coming
in so if you can just make sure that
your microphone is fine yeah okay
um is it better now
okay yeah yeah
okay so i wanted to talk about the
different resources
uh that you have access to as part of
the program
so bioinformatics in africa is an
initiative
by us buying biotech and our
collaborators
in nigeria and leed city university
so i will be giving you a quick overview
of the bioinformatics for genomic
medicine program
that we recently concluded on september
20th
right so we asked all of our
participants to give us
feedback on what they thought about the
program
and here is just a few of the
participant feedback from in and equin
young
and this is what they thought about the
program that we did
which was a short one week program
we also did a survey
of the different uh participants
and we wanted to see who are the
different people who are joining us
so we found out on this survey that we
had 13
of students who came from studies
we had 40 percent graduate students
or who are pursuing the graduate studies
we had 29 percent postgraduate students
15 percent phds
and two-person people who are from the
industry
so this survey helps us to understand uh
the kind of
participants we have for a program so
that we are
able to reach out to each of you because
everyone learns at
a different stage and this is how our
resources
our mentor support is going to help you
throughout the entire program
we also asked our participants about the
omics technology
they were more interested in so 18
persons said that they were interested
in learning about bioinformatics
and multi-omits as a whole 35 percent
which is a majority wanted to learn more
about genomics uh
20 percent about transcriptomics eight
percent metagenomics
then you have epigenetics uh ten percent
want to learn more about big data in
biology
and there's two person for immuno
informatics and proteomics
and there are others who have also want
to learn about different things
like agrobiotechnology so we will be
also
uh talking more about that later
and this is the certificate
um which uh a participant receives once
they
complete a program so
we give out certificate of participation
and
certificate of excellence for each of
our program
the certificate of excellence is based
upon the asynchronous course results
that a participant takes as part of the
program
so i will take you through the
registration process for the program
in a minute so this is the page that we
have
for africa it's called
africa.omicslogic.org
i just posted it on the chat so if you
look at this page you will be able to
see that
there are details about the program you
have
all of the syllabuses given right here
the date of the program each of the
sessions
the topics of the sessions and what are
the broad categories that are going to
be covered
and if you go down you'll be able to see
some testimonials
some of the courses which will be part
of
the program and learn more about
our team so i know that a lot of you
have questions about what is the pricing
and how you can get started with it
so we have made the program available um
with three membership levels so let me
just talk a little bit about the
membership level so you have a beginner
membership
level so the beginner actually gets
access
to the full program you get access to
both the edut bios of uh
platform the server t bio info platform
the codemix logic platform as part of
the program
and that starts at only 30 dollars a
month
and we also have intermediate the
intermediate
means that when someone is doing a
project they can request for a
one-on-one
session with our mentors while the
advanced
program which is for 75 dollars will
also not only include mentor support
but also will include access to
one more month for everyone to finish
their projects so this is a one month
program
but for someone who is looking to work
on their project which
may usually take longer than a month
they can continue to do so
if they have this license so this is the
division
now to make everything easier for
participants who are coming up like
students who are in africa we have a 20
discount code on each of these so for
example if i
select uh the dollar 31 so i select the
basic
beginner license now i can enter my card
details here and if i go to the coupon
this is the code take 33 off i'll post
it again in the chat and also email
everyone and if i click on apply
you will be able to see that you get uh
it for only dollar 20.10
so you can then continue to payments and
this is how you can register for the
program
we also have another payment link for
local payments in niger so if you want
uh that link you can request for that
and we'll be sending you that paystack
link
or if you want someone to pay for you in
nigeria
or in any other countries we have our
collaborators and you can request that
so for that please email me at marketing
at pine.bio for any kind of assistance
regarding
uh the registration process
and i will quickly move back to the
presentation right now
so as part okay the early bird
uh price expires by september 30th
so you have until like a week to
register
the program would be starting on october
5th
so the early bird will be expiring by
september
so just moving on you can also
come and join our community on both
facebook and linkedin i'll be posting
the links in a minute in the chat
and we have these groups where we have
people from
uh the industry from the community from
different universities who have come and
joined us in both of these groups so
this one is in facebook
and the mix logic machine learning group
is
in linkedin so please come join us
thank you so much dr mohan so if you
have any questions
right now you can post them in the chats
and we'll be taking questions
uh can we enroll for the program after
the program
dates we would not advise you to enroll
for the program after the program starts
uh the reason is this that you have to
go
the program follow the program as you
see there is a syllabus right so the
syllabus has been designed to make sure
that
you are starting the program from a
basic level and then you are going
towards advanced
so you may join the program if you think
you can make
up but if you say joining the program
for the third session or fourth session
it will be difficult for you to uh you
know follow through the program
so uh that is why i would not recommend
it but
yes if you want to you can go forward
but maybe it's good to mention that we
also have other programs
right yes yes yes so this is also
true thank you aelia for that so you can
join any other program so
as you see that we have students who are
uh
yes i shall get your question in a
minute so it's as i
did show you that we have students and
faculty
all of you all of who has different
interests so we have programs running
throughout the year so we have different
programs dedicated to
rna-seq analysis metagenomic data
analysis
data science so you can join any of
those programs
later this year and next year we have a
list of programs
that we can let you know that uh which
are coming up
we also uh have the
research fellowship that we offer for
students
uh currently there are around 15
research fellows
who are joining us from all around the
world
so you can also be a part of that
if you don't want to be part of this
program and you're interested in working
dedicatedly on your research project
so you have uh that as well okay so
let's go back
uh to the certificates right
um
okay thank you right
and uh asha to answer your questions
about the certificate right
so uh the certificate that we offer
are two different kinds of certificate
one is the certificate of excellence and
the certificate of participation
so the certificate of excellence is
given to anyone
who is enrolled in a one month program
who has over 10 000 points so how do you
get 10 000 points you get 10 000 points
uh when you do the different uh courses
when you do the different run different
pipelines and also do
different uh lessons on the code
omixlogic platform
so all of these would uh give you
certain points that will add up to your
final points which can be ten thousand
so people in a one-month program can
also get up to 20 000 points given how
much
active they are so this would depend on
your own
uh performance and uh
this is about the certificate of
excellence and certificate of
participation
or completion uh rather we would give it
to
anyone who has over 2000 points the
asynchronous courses help us to
understand whether
a participant is actually involved
in the program and how much they are
learning
because uh the asynchronous courses
supplement
all that is taught in the program if you
would notice the schedule
then all of our programs are not um i
mean
every day of the week there are a
limited number of gaps between each of
the programs so
that is the time that you can rehash and
refresh your learning of what you
learned
in the session with the synchronous
courses
run some pipelines on your own come back
to the mentors with any questions that
you can have
so it's a well-rounded learning
experience for you
okay thank you if there are any
questions please let us know
we are already uh coming close to the
end of the program
and uh elia if you would want to add
something
well briefly about the certification as
we mentioned the program material and
content is reviewed extensively by our
academic partners
but our major research partner is the
tapper bioinformatics research center at
the university of haiti in israel
it's a center dedicated to the testing
and development of new algorithmic
approaches for the analysis of
different types of comics data and they
are also helping certify the program
uh outcomes for our participants so it's
a joint
certificate between biotech and the
tower bioinformatics research center
and we are right now working with a
number of universities
in africa or starting to where
we we are hoping that we will develop
joint certification in the future as
well
thank you so much elia um
so if you all have any other questions
please post them uh
in the chats right now and uh we will be
reaching out to you via email with the
details of the program
and you can again always email us
regarding registration
or any other questions about resources
okay the 10 000 points again is
uh based on the
assessment and the activity that you do
on the three portals so all of our
portals are
interlinked with each other the edut bio
info portal
they are interlinked and the server t by
info so whenever you run a pipeline you
get
some points whenever you do a lesson on
codemix logic you get a point
right so i hope uh sunny that was uh
helpful to you uh if you have any other
questions you can let me know
for neha uh so if you're doing an
asynchronous course
you would be getting the certificate
right
on the uh profile of right in your
profile
so you have to look under courses and
then you will find certificates
so introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to genomics an introduction
to metagenomics
all have their own certificates which
are automatically generated
once you complete the courses
and you have to make sure that you click
on each module and click on complete
to make the to make the course complete
if you just go through a course the
course won't be complete
so if you have any questions with that
you can again email me
having upcoming program regarding ngs
application
and bioinformatics in food safety we
definitely have
many programs on ngs applications
uh one of our next program would be um
both metagenomics and transcriptomics
which are starting later this year
but regarding food safety so uh we do
not have something exactly
on the topic of food safety but
all of our programs are related to ngs
data so
you can learn from this program and
apply the learning to
your own analysis
so that could be an approach if you have
again any questions you can email me
marketing at pine.bio
okay so thank you everyone for joining
today
we will see you all again and please let
us know if you face any challenges
thank you thank you everybody